парламенті кричали давайте гроші на
армію а вони нам казали давайте гроші на
дороги півтора року введений воєнний
стан 1,5 року економіка має бути
переведена на воєнні рельси якого милого
ми до сих пір закуповуємо форму десь за
кордон в нашому немає потужності я
розумію як це треба робити перевести в
наказовому порядку підприємство для
потреб армії і це стосується не тільки
форми це має стосуватися і різних сил і
засобів це не місяць це не півріччя це
півтора року Тут виникає проблема
професійності тих людей які сьогодні
приймають управлінські рішення
врешті-решт треба щоби дорослі
професійні люди змінили отих які не
можуть собі дати раду бо із-за цього
терплять люди і за цього терплять
економіка і за цього терплять держава бо
якщо хтось не виробляє тут в тилу то
хтось не отримує на передньому краї